bye bye year 22 and welcome to 2023. I
had meant to do a end of 2022 wrap up
and review video but you know we
actually scheduled the double whammy
covet and flu vaccine for just days
before and that left me kind of wiped
out so I had a very low key end of the
year and now I'm feeling much better so
it's you know about time to do a little
bit of a review a bit belatedly but you
know that that's quite all right so 2022
was an interesting year a year that a
lot got done and also kind of a tough
year in many respects um you know
health-wise I wound up finally getting
covid I think that I probably got it
going to Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Designs uh exhibit night where we
faculty got to go in the seniors do
their senior thesis which is a really
really big deal at my ad and you know
their family is there for preview night
and then of course we professors get to
go in and check out all of our students
work and you know see the cool things
that they did but it's a lot of people
coming in from out of town and you know
gathered together in some pretty small
spaces so I'm pretty sure that's where I
got it and it was no joke you know
fortunately I didn't have to be
hospitalized or anything but man it took
all the chronic pain that I have and
like turned it up to 11 in my joints and
muscles and there was the coughing and
the sneezing and all the other stuff and
worst of all I gave my child cat covid
as well and she wound up being isolated
at University of wisconsin-milwaukee so
end of the semester kind of sucked you
know for both of us not a lot of fun
another big thing that happened that was
kind of a damper was in April actually
just you know weeks before I got kovid
and it's kind of fortunate in a way as
my wife has pointed out
the last of our four-legged family sassy
AKA sassy pants the assassinator she's
got many other names
she at 19 years old got you know sick
she'd always been kind of like going up
and down for the last few years she'd
lose a lot of weight and then gain it
back or seemed like she was getting sick
but this time she actually got sick for
the the final time and you know over the
course of three or four days I was
spending a lot of my time with her
um you know she stopped being able to
eat and drink effectively and her body
just gave out and it was it was very sad
but um you know she died here at home
surrounded by me and Andy you know
telling her how much that we loved her
you know looking into each other's eyes
and um you know she was my constant
companion and I was hers especially
since the Covenant epidemic right so
that was that was quite hard as well and
I miss her every day especially when I
go downstairs uh make myself some coffee
and you know get some food ready that I
would usually take in and give her a
little snack and pets and stuff like
that so you know those are some somber
parts of the year it was also kind of a
big year for teaching not as heavy as
some years in the past where I've taught
as much as 15 classes in a calendar year
but I did still teach quite a bit
academic classes I taught eight this
last year five of them for Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design I actually
took over a class early on in the
semester for a colleague of mine who had
to you know had to go for medical
reasons so I took over his upper level
senior writing class and saw them
through to the the very end that meant
that I only taught one class last
semester because you can only teach five
as an Adjunct professor there
I also finished up teaching for Carthage
College in the spring teaching a
medieval philosophy class and then we
parted ways and their philosophy
department is completely phased out the
major is gone so there's a whole story
there that could be told about how they
did that and I'm no longer teaching
business ethics for them either in part
because there's a new chair who insisted
that all the classes should be face to
face and I was like yeah I'm not going
down to Kenosha for that I also got uh
this this fall asked to teach three
classes for Marquette University where
I've taught in the past and
um
two of them were this upper level core
class that I situated around the topic
of anger and then one was foundations of
philosophy which is sort of like intro
to philosophy just with a few extra
bells and whistles that uh were added by
a committee and so I did a lot of
academic teaching which meant a lot of
grading a lot of uh interacting with
with students and colleagues and stuff
like that and I also worked with a
company called light Hall which at the
time uh seemed like a very good
opportunity they've subsequently pivoted
and changed their orientation so it's
it's less of a a great fit for
philosophy at this point in time but I
taught a class on Aristotle's nickel
McKay and ethics the moral virtues and
eight weeks class and a six-week class
that just finished up in December on
Plato's dialogues and we're going to
recycle those classes again in 2023 and
offer them in the study with Sadler
Academy so if you're hearing that you're
like oh I wish I could have gotten in on
those classes you'll have an opportunity
for that so a lot of teaching a lot of
developing resources and um
that was kind of cool some of those
resources I'll talk about in the uh
stuff about videos but before that
what else went on in in 2022 well I got
to do a lot more exercise you know
during covid at the very beginning I
started you know I couldn't go to the
gym you know for a long time so I would
take walks all around the city you might
have seen some of the photos that I've
taken over the recent years in these
different neighborhoods around here that
I I walk around in and I've gotten to
know the city at least this part of it
pretty well so I know like where I want
to go and what's blooming at what time
and you know where the cool places are
and what to avoid as well so I do take
some long walks and I've done that over
the course of the year but I also did
get back to the gym and started doing
weight circuit training you know
sometimes less regularly sometimes more
covid really put a big
Kink into that because I I did suffer
some effects you know lasting past the
initial infection
making me a bit more tired when I would
exercise and you know things things
along those lines
but you know overall it's been pretty
good I've I've over the last year I've
lost about 30 pounds and it's not
actually like losing 30 pounds
completely because what I what ended up
happening is a net loss of 30 pounds
which means a lot of fat got lost or
burned off rather and then I added some
muscle which is good as well and the
muscle is good for keeping the fat off
right because muscle demands more energy
to to keep itself going it's kind of a
virtuous cycle and you know getting back
into the gym there have been some ups
and downs you know so some of it
involves some mental adjustment you know
there's there's like you get to a
certain level with the weights you've
been making some gains and then you know
you can't go for a while then you got to
start out at a lower level well that
takes some mental Readjustment which is
which is is good for me as well
what else you know it's it's been quite
an active year as far as tutorials I
picked up a number of new clients and
um you know doing philosophical
counseling with some clients uh some
academic coaching here and there
got brought in on you know quite a few
uh projects uh here and there as well so
so that's that's good and you know I
this might actually be the year that I
start getting my act together as far as
marketing goes I'm very fortunate in
that so far everybody's sought me out I
haven't like advertised or marketed or
anything like that and I've had a pretty
steady flow of clients coming to me to
work on interesting and challenging
matters using the resources of
philosophy
um what else so you know I'm a team
member of the modern stoicism
organization and you know I I helped
along with my my wife and a few other
people to organize the annual stoicon
conference which went quite well we we
actually had almost no problems uh in
the course of the the conference which
is almost unheard of for something
that's online so you know everybody
showed up where they're supposed to we
didn't have any terrible tiffs or
technology failures or anything like
that so that was that was really awesome
we raised a good bit of money for the
modern stoicism organization
um Leia goldrick and I also managed to
bring out the uh fourth volume in
stoicism today selected essays we'd
brought out volume three in 2021 and we
brought out volume four this year so
that's really cool you know another
edited volume uh the proceeds of which
go to the modern stoicism organize
so that was really quite quite awesome
and lovely and then
what else oh I stepped down as of the
end of the year as the editor of
stoicism today a role that I took out in
2016 so you know almost seven years had
passed and I thought it was time to you
know move on and bring on some fresh new
eyes and new blood so my assistant
editor and good friend and colleague
Harold coveley has moved up from
assistant Editor to to full editor and
Judith stove who is also you know a good
friend and very competent at what she
does and a great addition to the team
actually join the modern stoicism team
and came on as the assistant editor so
I'm happy leaving stoicism today in some
really competent hands and that'll give
me a bit more time to do some of the
work that that I want to do as as well
I got some writing work done
I've been working on taking the videos
that I did the commentary videos on
epictetuses and caridian taking the
transcripts from them cleaning them up
you know editing them and I'm turning
them slowly into a book form and I've
I've released them in serial form to my
patreon supporters and in medium and
eventually it's going to turn into
hopefully later on this year of 2023
into a new book that um will you know be
helpful for people in studying this
great short work of stoic philosophy
speaking of medium I managed to write 71
medium posts in the last year which is
you know pretty good not as not as much
as I'd like to but you know got some
writing done which is nice and I've you
know I've got my three different
Publications heavy metal philosopher
practical rationality and then Gregory
very Sadler PhD publishing in all of
those I might start publishing in 2023
and some other places as well but you
know we'll see what happens
um YouTube I think most of you probably
know me from YouTube and it's not a
surprise since you're watching this
right on YouTube right now
so it was a pretty good year
350 videos so not a video a day but
pretty close you know there's there's uh
some days that I I didn't release
anything
um
you know started some new things uh some
merch offering memberships
um started new video series like the
Sadler's quick takes and you know
um kept going on with like Sadler's
stories and book reviews and all of that
and I I did want to point out that
113 core concept videos I'm you know I
it's still nowhere near like full
coverage of even just the history of
Western philosophy but you know we're
filling in the gaps so doing the
medieval philosophy class was kind of
good because I didn't have that much in
that section so I did more videos on
Augustine and on uh Anselm who you know
I had videos on already but I got to
churn out a lot more and then there were
two other medieval authors who I hadn't
done
um prudentius this really Latin poet
early medieval I mean uh his cycle
machia and alquin who I've been a fan of
for quite a long time this great
Benedictine scholar associated with uh
Charlemagne and the carolaginian
Renaissance so I did one of his works as
well
and a bunch of others I mean I just
recently finished up a sequence on David
hume's inquiry concerning human
understanding
um you know all sorts of other cool
stuff along the way doing doing the
anger classes gave me an opportunity to
do some work on you know Aristotle and
Plutarch and Seneca and also you know
contemporary figures like audre Lorde uh
her work the uses of anger so lots and
lots of core concept videos
um it wasn't a great year for half hour
Hegel I did manage to get 23 new
commentary videos done and we're almost
at the very end of the religion section
of hegel's phenomenology so the end is
in sight we've just got one more video
to do in that and then we're into
absolute knowing
um what else uh you know world's a
speculative fiction we kept up the new
format I did nine sessions in that plus
one special interview
with the author of dare to know James
Kennedy which which was kind of cool to
do
um what else you know the wisdom for
Life radio show uh we're now making less
Headway that we used to be every two
weeks we'd put out a new episode this
year we did 13 episodes so really about
one a month but you know it's still uh
doing quite good uh you know I think
that this coming year will probably get
back to doing one every two weeks who
knows maybe we'll even step it up to new
episode every week so if you like you
know Community radio that you can listen
to online everywhere and you're into
philosophy you probably want to check
out the wisdom for Life show and what
else did we do
well you know the Sadler's lectures
podcast which I make from core concept
videos I managed to release
270 podcast episodes so you know
definitely not one a day but
you know that's quite a lot so that's
pretty cool you know we passed up the
800 episode Mark oh I should point out
too with YouTube
um I think that I passed the hundred
thousand subscriber Mark in 2021 but
they sent me the special you know silver
YouTube play button plaque in uh 2022
when I think I had around like maybe
150 15
000 subscribers so it was a little bit
later on but kind of cool you know to
see that I do have some other stats
about uh YouTube videos so 1.8 million
views this year of the videos that I've
done which is you know for a
low-tech philosophy oriented Channel
pretty good
um here's something kind of
mind-boggling so 255
thousand hours watched now I put that
into the calculator and you know 24
hours in a day and 365 uh days in a year
so that means in the last year
uh the videos that I've produced have
been watched for
29.14 years worth
that's pretty incredible you know a lot
of uh what would you call it return on
investment in at least in terms of time
right so that's that's pretty cool it's
getting to see that they're getting
traction they're getting used they're
getting viewed it's not just the views
themselves but the the fact that people
are watching them or listening to them
for hours and hours and using them as
resources so I'm very happy about that
and you know I'm going to continue
producing videos for the uh
foreseeable future I mean probably at
least another decade hopefully YouTube
stays as a stable platform and doesn't
go away if it does I've got most of the
videos backed up on hard drives here and
there what else it was a good year for
guest appearances and talks I got
invited to quite a few that were
stoicism related including a stoicism
Midwest that I was the only midwesterner
I actually attending a lot of other cool
things as well over the course of the
year we you know went back to doing the
philosophers in the midst of History uh
series
um there there was a little Interruption
we didn't get to do the episode or the
session on Bonaventure because I had
covid right but we're going to do that
this coming year so if you're into
franciscans you know you might want to
tune in or even show up and and we had a
lot of other great events as well you
know all sorts of things coming onto
podcasts and shows and you know giving
talks uh invited here and there so that
was a lot of fun
and uh what else should I mention well
you know it's been a year of a lot of
cooking and uh family and you know
reading and writing and all of these
sorts of things that are that are quite
important
um our city here is growing and
developing and despite the attempts by
some of the legislators in Wisconsin to
choke the crap out of it it's
doing pretty well we elected a new mayor
who is helming things quite quite well
and you know all sorts of other good
things happening in this this region as
well so you know 22s 2022 has been kind
of a mixed year but I would say at least
for you know uh me and my immediate
family overall a pretty good year and so
I hope that you're 2022 was good for you
and uh look forward to you know hearing
what you have to say about the year and
about the different things that I just
mentioned or that you want to know more
about and I'll see all of you hopefully
uh down the line somewhere either in the
ether the internet the interwebs or
maybe even face to face this year of
2023.